real quick Kyle real quick what up with
these [ __ ] Macho Man Randy [ __ ]
Savage baby yeah just got done playing
basketball at 6:00 a.m. run feels real
real real real real real real good let's
go all right guys look at this
ridiculous scene what we're doing now is
we're shooting some imagery for the
speakers I've got coming out Kyle's a
big first day no longer dailyvee virgin
he's filming for the first time davin
[ __ ] up yesterday but he's redeeming
himself
d-roc is finally doing something
productive things are good out here
looking around we got it once people
wonder if we got it we're out of here
[ __ ] rad super super rad drop in
November 14th both men's and women's
that we got all the looks yeah I'm gonna
be a complex Khan in the booth so we got
some pairs there don't when I drop them
on case with his website I'll be some
giveaways they're gonna be available
what like 10 or 15 shots right not how
many stores a limited run look at the
pencils of promise Club kind of look
really handsome I can't wait for these
[ __ ] to come out put up vlog first of
all Kyle my man Kyle filming his first
episode Big Ups to you my man let's tag
you up I was sitting here doing the
photo shoot my new kicks that are coming
out to Gary be a 102 case was collab
dropping November 14th my 42nd birthday
as somebody once said in the comments
section if you thought that the 16 year
old me thought when I'm 42 I'm gonna
drop my kicks
super excited thanks for all the support
can't wait for this project to come out
great day today it's gonna be
interesting to la be I don't know how
Kyle's gonna navigate all day meetings
then jumping jumping on the flight
heading out to Cleveland Bone Thugs baby
the calves and the Celtics kick off the
season looking forward to it hang on man
David leaving president Turner one of
the best executives
in the world let alone the entertainment
space so should be a fun day leave some
comments and I'll check you later
check check check and check you later yo
but real quick Kyle real quick what up
with these [ __ ] Macho Man Randy
[ __ ] salads baby yeah
[Music]
how am i cool er at 42 that I was at 24
and by the way it's not even remotely
close blog I'm telling you it's not
close all right good job I really do
thank you
[Music]
hi
[Music]
I love this company
[Music]
how do you think good look an answer for
you
[Music]
that's Friday now cuz I'm going to the
Cavs Celtics game um LeBron and Wade
really wanted me there I'm kidding
I know it's it's scary the back that
even the fact that that even has a
chance of being true is funny go fast
always know that you have a much better
chance if it's fifty seven and it's oh
three means I'm three minutes late keep
it in mind go fast I'm overly overly
reliant on my intuition and at this
point also on my experience you just
become one with your decisions but in my
early days I which for a lot of people
here who don't make hundreds of
decisions a day I just go with my
intuition it's the lack of fear of
failing that has allowed me to make
decisions people don't make decisions
because they're scared to lose I make
decisions because I want to know what's
gonna happen and then I build on top of
that and now I'm just into that Zen
state of like experience and intuition
I'm in the I'm just starting to after
that prime of decision-making the next
twenty years are gonna look good on
decision making for me it's just the
volume of things you can do when you
don't debate I think then it's a net
score I just genuinely think being right
seven out of fourteen times is better
than being right two out of two times
because I'm on offense these things are
things that are making things happen
no no it comes down to self belief
self-confidence empathy reality check
and not a not and just not worrying
about what other people think and having
great intent never done anything for the
wrong reason between the between this is
important like you can read this and
think wow this guy's got a ton of
confidence or too much ego it's the
intent part it's when you're coming from
a good intent like I'm never worried
about losing because when I have to then
unroll it for others nobody's gonna be
like wow what an idiot
- what a bad person so if I lose I lose
the last thing how do you what's the
difference between making large life
decisions and sort of smaller so
companies that you're gonna have an a
where you're gonna live there's stuff
there the 99% of things don't matter and
on the biggest things it's always better
to go with your gut than to overthink it
the more you think about it the more you
talk yourself out of it good morning
good morning everyone morning morning
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
meetings nice one you see that that's
how you do it folks
Seth nope alright music I want to record
a post roll commercial for the wine club
on the podcast yep the greatest gift for
the holiday season
in the history of mankind the garyvee
wine of the Month Club $55 delivered go
sign up now to winelibrary.com slash
garyvee yep
hey guys this is a Vimeo exclusive video
Vimeo the high quality video platform
and this is one high quality video it's
funny right it's so funny that I
literally am like a human media output
er it's so crazy
so my team out here is doing jack [ __ ]
and so I'm gonna be making my own
content for these sneakers cuz I don't
know why these characters are just
bullshitting but in the souls some of my
favorite [ __ ] quotes tongue what is
it's called a tongue I think so too
got the signature got the cork laces
love that can't wait drops eleven
fourteen pre-order now pre-order now
pre-order now pre-order now
[Music]
yep like when Gary was talking at the
beginning I texted him I said is this
guy full of [ __ ] you know like I he's
like I didn't know Gary was on my radar
I think I got an immediate response to
Cubans saying no he's legit he's
actually when I smartest guys in the
space I have a Tamils back four very
cool yeah that matters I also got asked
to be Cubans co-host at a CES wine
dinner yep
you remember he came to Boehner you
weren't there that day not only three
one five in the glass case we weren't
doing vlogging yet that's cool yeah yeah
man listen it's all gonna work out the
truth is undefeated it was crazy about
Cuban he's also [ __ ] legit us Bach
this [ __ ] smart man
[ __ ] have a lot of respect - I just
got an idea
[Music]
really okay
[Applause]
a little Brady Bunch
[Music]
[Music]
first name first what made you want to
partner with Kos I'm obsessed with
nostalgia look at the setting behind me
yeah I think I saw just one of the great
you know undervalued assets in our
society also piece list is such a
historical rad-brad right going all the
way back to it I Steve's like already a
gangster yeah and and just sneakily
super fascinating we're seeing massive
fragmentation collaborations and you
know felt like you know you know before
athletes started rocking sneakers being
the face of them that just wasn't a
thing right before celebrities started
doing it wasn't a thing I thought it
would be interesting if an entrepreneur
would Rakesh sneaker just see what
happens if it works it's a my legacy
forever is kind of the first mantra for
a really go at it and if it failed it's
an inside joke with me and my buddies
for them to harass me with so and what
point did you just say that this was
going to be your shoe this was gonna be
an airing be zero zero one zero zero two
instead of you just rocking cake to us
and being a brand ambassador I would
have never I've never been a brand
ambassador in my life yeah that were
runs through my mind yeah so either I do
a real collaboration or
the brand outright which has a lot to do
with the way I'm thinking about building
bigger medians even believe so I think
that she's gonna appeal to both
entrepreneurs and sneakerheads that's a
good question I think entrepreneurs
wouldn't really be attracted to it so
she wants they give any crap about me
whatsoever interested it's just a fun
moment for all of us in it just the
entrepreneurial Network I think
sneakerheads it was key for me to do
several little things for example just
little things that I thought they were
really appreciate like like getting
ahead not to my wine days just you know
the inside soles like the box which we
don't have here sooner thought a little
bit addition rather than the
distribution of it watching in a complex
con they're just doing things and just
in general I think a lot of people that
are closely paying attention what's
happening with me I over index as an
entrepreneur I think would sneakerheads
in that culture what are some of your
favorite shoes as a senior head the
Patrick Ewing in this sneaker Wow we
absolutely way back doesn't it may have
a comeback right for me because I hated
Michael Jordan's I never owned a pair of
Air Jordans really really why the pumps
like the first pumps okay yeah I was a
big feel of Grant Hill rocking her back
in the day so you know and then I was a
huge Air Force One I mean for my mare a
lot of Air Force one said it was
actually important to kudos to Kate's
West when we did this you know one of my
biggest things was look I have to be
able to wear other things I can't just
you know my sneakers or k-swiss
24/7 and they had the foresight to see
that the world's a little more inclusive
and so I'll still be able to wear you
know
you should showed me oh I was uh that
was maybe the sealer for me of openness
and their smartness of how the whole
thing actually works is this going to be
a limited or a widely available release
limited I think there's less than ten
thousand right yes less than ten
thousand sneakers from the accommodation
of one and twos is the 14th of our date
Hardy okay my birthday my police say huh
sorry so that's why I Murphy are we're
going to see possibly a three or four
and now you were talking high top if
they're more in the works but case works
out and which I'm hopeful and I think
they're hopeful will be afraid for next
year hey guys uh so an interesting day
right like photo shoot for my sneakers
and a meeting meeting meeting meeting
meeting and now I'm in a couple of
minutes flying off to it flying off to
Cleveland for the opening of the NBA
season I am on an absolutely quest to on
an everyday basis produce a singular
piece of content that empowers you to go
do your thing
I've got mine I'm gonna get mine my
obsession of you getting yours has never
been greater and I will spend the next
50 years of my life trying to put you on
to the path that my parents and my
circumstance allowed me and I promise
you my competitive juices is a huge
factor to why I'm succeeding in my
entrepreneurial ventures
[Music]
now I'm gonna focus on the games so
everybody has a good night
[Applause]
[Music]